the idea of paradox is ancient like
literally ancient and it's not just
mathematical I feel you as I went around
you had maths involved in you statement
but one of the reason why I like all of
these is because paradoxes are bigger
than that I'll give you an example one
of the most famous paradox is called the
liar paradox some of you might have
heard it before okay very simple
statement one sentence this sentence is
a lie this sentence is alike think about
it very sure this sentence is a lie
let's just consider what happens what
happens if it's right well if it's right
then the statements not a lie it's true
but wait that doesn't work because it
says that it's a lie so it my brain okay
so that's not um that's not mathematical
at all in in a similar kind of vein can
you imagine what would happen if
Pinocchio said to you my nose is about
to grow
so so then so for those of you my mate
right
so kenickie's nose should grow if he
lies right well if the statement is
aligned his nose will grow but wait he
just said my name is going to grow which
means it's true and again it's the same
of you that's just a variation on the
lie apparels okay so I really like all
of these somebody doesn't work a
contradictory statement I might add to
that and you might be able to tell from
the two examples I just gave you often
we end up with paradoxes where the
statements or ideas are self referential
that's a really important idea self
referential ideas things that refer to
themselves are often paradoxical okay a
statement that breaks the more so things
are generally accepted to be true but
then something comes along and it's it's
true as well but it disagrees with other
things right or masculine here a
falsification which is also considered
the truth I really like this enviably
gotten clear at the end because this is
going to get that there are two big
classes of paradoxes okay and this was
I'd like you all to write this down and
you have this this is kind of underneath
this idea I'm just going to try and
reread a little bit that should make
kinds of paradoxes are things that are
true right but they seem false right you
say to someone in a like nerd really nor
but yeah really
okay alternatively the other kind and he
guesses what the other kind my things
good the other way around okay things
that you know if you apply your logic
and your deduction all that kind of
thing you're like this is true this is
true this is true and what you end up
with you know even though it seems true
is actually a why so we're gonna have a
look at some kinds of these we're going
to start off by having a look at our at
this kind of category right these are
often called this particular kind of
paradox is often called a fallacy what
I'm going to do is I'm going to try and
come up with things that seem to hold
together that seem valid that use the
rules you're familiar with and you agree
with it but I'm gonna end with something
which is clearly wrong okay so here's
our classic one we'll start with the
algebraic one which is let you're gonna
start off with two numbers a and B but
they're actually the same numbers so
long as they're not zero two numbers not
zero you happy so far
so there's not a complicated idea you
can have numbers that are the same all
the time but what are we going to do
with them right by the way when you spot
what's wrong because within this room
thinking about what we've been doing
over the past past few months I hope
I'll be able to do this slowly nothing
cleaner but you should see it
immediately I heard if I've done my job
okay but always just shout it out I just
want you to let me run my course okay
because it makes a nice result
here's where I'm gonna do of this I'm
gonna multiply both sides by a excuse me
this
I'm then going to you should've I'm
pretty much I'm shouldn't pretty sure
everyone has seen some variations it's
okay I'm going to subtract B squared
from both sides now this point I've got
a whole bunch of terms I can factorize
here
it's only a factorize over here and I'm
going to factorize over here okay I have
some common factors so I'll get rid of
both what's common on both sides I'll
get rid of that okay so far pretty
ordinary but I know that a is equal to B
that's how I started off right sir it
looks to me like two equals one gotcha
okay now say nothing okay raise your
hand if you can see where the problem is
okay all right good I'm very glad to get
you to shout out because that means it
quite a few of you still need to think
it through okay there are not that many
lions here the error must be hiding in
there somewhere you know it must be
because this can't be true right so
where is it
all right so there you go fallacy number
one